[Música]
i
el calidad de los tenis de la tragedia
del jaque para formar billion por la
morge de ayer
pero como por todos
nizar van a parece saber que se dirige a
su público por última vez
[Música]
tres días después de la publicación de
este vídeo el activista político fue
asesinado por los servicios de seguridad
palestinos
con más de 100 mil seguidores en redes
sociales niesr banat denunciado con
fuerza la corrupción que gangrena la
autoridad nacional palestina
sorprendente y es curioso que en el
mundo del fútbol málaga la patria
y auto iconografía
nizar van a murió mientras las fuerzas
de seguridad lo transferían al hospital
lo detuvieron y lo subieron inconsciente
a un vehículo
[Música]
estas imágenes de una de las cámaras de
vigilancia hacen parte del expediente
judicial
[Música]
hamid y husein son los primos de mis
hermanas asistieron al asesinato los
tres estaban dormidos en la casa cuando
los hombres de la unidad entraron en
medio de la noche
michelle estaba dormido aquí tenía el
rostro hacia la pared
el grupo entró el tipo que tenía la
barra de metal se puso aquí y empezó a
golpearlo con todas sus fuerzas
en ese momento me imagino que ingresar
no pensó que lo que estaba pasando
afuera
de repente se despertó y dijo muy
despacio qué está pasando
y sal dijo que está pasando y giró su
cabeza el resto del grupo se lanzó sobre
él lo rodearon había por lo menos nueve
o diez en el rincón y no paraban de
golpearlo
nissan empezó a respirar con dificultad
su respiración era entrecortada
no podía respirar bien los golpes no se
detenía lo trajeron aquí sus manos
estaban atadas lo tenían así empezaron a
golpear su cabeza contra el muro sin
parar más de cinco o seis veces ya no
podía estar de pie ellos tuvieron que
cargarlo
la autoridad palestina primero afirmó
que ni ser banal falleció por causas
naturales
pero la autopsia solicitada por la
familia indicó que la muerte fue
provocada por 42 golpes con barras de
hierro
hablando en serio ni share a bin laden
nunca les lanzó una piedra nunca les
disparó nunca los amenazó con un arma yo
nada era un opositor político ni zar
hacía política así que los criticaba
luchaba contra ellos con palabras
criticaba su corrupción quería cambiar
eso nada más
después del anuncio de su muerte se
entonó un canto inédito en las calles de
ramala
[Música]
por primera vez los palestinos se
dirigen directamente contra sus
gobernantes los manifestantes marchan
hacia el palacio presidencial donde
reside mahmud abás elegido en 2005 para
un mandato de cuatro años el presidente
de la autoridad palestina nunca abandonó
el poder acaba de anular las primeras
elecciones generales previstas en 16
años la muerte de mis hermanas candidato
a las elecciones tuvo en efecto
catalizador
vine para protestar contra la autoridad
palestina
[Música]
contra su represión en su opresión
salimos a las calles porque mataron a
sin arba nada
todas las manifestaciones son reprimidas
las fuerzas del orden no se ven por las
calles los manifestantes son perseguidos
por los miembros del fatah el movimiento
nacional de liberación de palestina
el partido de mahmud abás que controlan
la autoridad palestina confiscan
celulares e intimidan físicamente a los
que pronuncian consignas anti a base
de policías vestidos de civil se llevan
a algunos manifestantes otros son
rociados con gas pimienta por los
seguidores de mahmud abás no puede ser
que es esto hablamos decimos una palabra
limpio de golpes nos golpean porque
hablamos a qué leyes obedece esto todos
denuncian un régimen corrupto la
autoridad palestina es el principal
empleador en cisjordania la asignación
de miles de empleos públicos está
gobernada por el nepotismo la
administración del presupuesto no es
clara y la población está agotada siguió
aumentando y aumentando con hace mucho
que nos controlan con los impuestos por
ejemplo nos cobraron puestos pedirá a
dónde va no lo sabemos no sirve de nada
porque hay corrupción mire el estado de
las calles se redistribuyen los
proyectos entre ellos son los dueños de
los restaurantes todo lo que hay en este
país les pertenece a dónde va el dinero
que ahora sabemos del extranjero lo
utilizan para las tiendas para los
restaurantes nosotros estamos aquí con
la boca abierta suficiente estamos
hartos pero ahora estamos aquí solo
porque mataron a una persona
hoy se enfrentan dos palestinas de un
lado los manifestantes que se oponen a
la corrupción y a la tendencia
autoritaria de sus dirigentes del otro
los seguidores del fatah el partido de
más nuevas que acusan a la multitud de
seguir el juego de su enemigo jurado
jamás el partido islamista en el poder
en gaza
unos 60 manifestantes son detenidos
[Música]
profesores poetas activistas o incluso
estudiantes
algunos son llevados delante a los
tribunales por haber participado en una
concentración ilegal
[Música]
la unión europea' principal patrocinador
financiero de la autoridad palestina
denunció esta ola de represión pero el
poder no le hizo mucho caso como lo
comprobó rápidamente hanan ashrawi
hace dos años esta figura de la política
palestina renunció al comité ejecutivo
de la olp la organización de liberación
de palestina
se cansó del ambiente cada vez más
autocrático y afirma que las recientes
críticas hechas por la comunidad
internacional no tuvieron mucho efecto
sobre mahmud abás
había mucha presión sobre los dirigentes
particularmente sobre el presidente
o eso aparentaba lo que hizo fue
seleccionar gente entre sus aliados
a quienes invitaron a líderes de la
sociedad civil a una reunión con el
presidente
se volvió un ejército de comunicación y
no había una agenda ni objetivos ni
compromisos
simplemente se trataba de una cita de un
encuentro para escuchar al presidente y
volver a la casa
[Música]
y después que cuál fue el resultado de
todo esto
los miembros de la organización nos
reunimos y preparamos un documento
político
basado en principios que se debían
respetar
transparencia respeto de la ley etcétera
y no obtuvimos ninguna respuesta nunca
muchas personas quedaron muy
decepcionada
es cierto que yo podría haberles dicho
que renuncien porque trate de cambiar
las cosas desde el interior durante años
pero nadie escucha nunca
sí
mientras el poder se repliega sobre sus
servicios de seguridad la represión
continúa silenciosamente
[Música]
cuatro meses después del funeral de mis
hermanas su familia organiza un elogio
fúnebre en ramala
unos 15 policías palestinos se ubican en
la entrada del lugar
junto a hassan su hermano están sentados
los dos hijos de mis hermanas
el fa
[Música]
wallace
entre el público hay muchos jóvenes
palestinos que salieron de las calles
justo después del asesinato
la aceituna periodista fue golpeada por
las fuerzas de seguridad durante las
primeras concentraciones le robaron su
celular
aunque ahora las manifestaciones se han
detenido las intimidaciones por parte
del organismo de seguridad continúan
recibí amenazas de enjuiciamiento y
algunos me amenazaron de violación ha
pasado varias veces las amenazas han
seguido hasta hoy me amenazaron 40 días
después de la muerte amenazar yo todavía
estaba herida y brazo todavía estaba
vendado no se había curado me amenazaron
y me dijeron esta vez te rompimos el
brazo la próxima vez te romperemos la
cabeza
todavía tienen mi celular no me lo han
devuelto al contrario han seguido
haciendo provocaciones a través de mis
celulares publican fotos privadas
conversaciones privadas ahora además de
eso hicieron algo que realmente me dio
miedo algo que me hizo pensar que ya no
estaba segura piratearon mi cuenta de
instagram y subieron historias en nombre
mío no seas diciendo que estaba
desesperada y que quería asustarme
varios me vigilaban me afirmaban en el
colegio de los niños en la universidad
hasta en mi lugar de trabajo incluso hoy
aquí adentro hay personas que hemos
aprendido a reconocer sabemos que están
presentes y que en este momento nos
están filmando
[Música]
unos meses después los dirigentes de la
autoridad palestina se reunieron para
conmemorar la muerte de esa gente erekat
una figura fundamental en todas las
negociaciones de paz con israel
mohamed shteye et el primer ministro
palestino está en primera fila es
considerado como el posible sucesor de
mahmud abás
[Música]
la audiencia escucha una locución
pregrabada del presidente con 86 años
enfermo casi no hace apariciones
públicas
por lo tanto más que el presidente el
primer ministro es la voz principal de
la autoridad palestina al ser
interrogado sobre la represión de las
manifestaciones
mohamed shtaye afirma que fue un error
y hemos hecho algunas personas
responsables por lo que pasó en ramala
después de las manifestaciones no
negamos lo que pasó pero como dije
hay personas que cruzaron los límites
nosotros no lo autorizamos y nos
oponemos a esto
al ser interrogado sobre la muerte de
nizar vanak el jefe del gobierno vuelve
a afirmar que fue un error
un caso
es uno solo y único caso
lo lamentamos
es triste para la familia
ese hombre murió en manos de nuestras
fuerzas de seguridad 14 agentes de las
fuerzas de seguridad fueron arrestados
están siendo juzgados en un tribunal
abierto eso pasa pero estamos llevando
el caso de la mejor manera posible
para la familia de mis hermanas las
excusas de la autoridad palestina no
tienen sentido
su hermano hassan afirma que iniciar
sabía que iba a morir
para él los agentes palestinos
responsables del asesinato ejecutaron
órdenes que venían desde arriba
en medio del ramadán dispararon contra
la casa de nizar después de que hubiera
una campaña de información contra él en
redes sociales todo eso pasó después del
envío de una carta a la unión europea
para pedirles que dejaran de financiar a
la autoridad palestina nizar era uno de
los firmantes de la carta que nosotros
publicaron fotomontajes con la cara de
mi zar sobre soldados israelíes durante
dos días hubo decenas y decenas de
imágenes como esa
el tercer día dispararon contra su casa
luego nizar se refugió en la casa de
nuestro pib en el sur ahí recibimos
varias llamadas anónimas en las que
decían que iban a matar a nizar que iban
a ejecutar a nizar esa clase de cosas
a través de intermediarios la autoridad
palestina le propuso a las familias un
acuerdo amistoso antes de que iniciara
el juicio de los presuntos asesinos una
humillación más para el clan van a
no quieren que nos callemos
que nos quedemos en silencio y darnos la
cantidad de dinero que pidamos
pero estamos muy lejos de todo eso
quieren ofrecernos otras cosas
como cargos posiciones importantes y
encargarse de los gastos de los hijos de
nizar pero no
no aceptaremos ninguna de sus ofertas
queremos un juicio justo no queremos
dinero
mataron a un hombre que piensan que va a
pasar después
qué esperan de nosotros que aceptemos su
dinero y nos olvidemos de nizar
estamos frente a una autoridad obtusa
autoritaria no nos protege es la
autoridad de los monstruos
son monstruos que matan durante la noche
que golpean durante la noche y durante
el día dicen que son inocentes
publica en las redes sociales una sola
foto de niza
y jefe me dijo que estaba prohibido
publicar mensajes de duelo en las redes
sociales en lo que respecta a nizar
guárdate el duelo para ti
como debería educar a mi hijo le digo
que su padre y ghassan es el hermano del
martes nizar y cuando me pregunta quién
mató a nizar que le debo decir la
autoridad palestina como lo voy a
inculcar a mi hijo el amor por la patria
la lealtad a la patria cuando los hijos
de esta patria se matan entre ellos
[Música]
mejor
en la región de hebrón territorio de mis
hermanas
la autoridad palestina es cada vez más
cuestionada
a causa de la represión pero sobre todo
a causa de un sentimiento de abandono
frente a la violencia de los colonos
israelíes
[Música]
hago esto todas las mañanas empecé a
hacerlo en 2017 y lo sigo haciendo ahora
moja más de 17 años recoge a los niños
que vienen del pueblo vecino
escoltados por el ejército israelí
los niños atraviesan un camino que pasa
por una colonia para llegar hasta su
escuela los palestinos adultos no tienen
derecho a caminar por ahí
[Música]
es el camino del pueblo detuvo a los
colonos lo cerraron porque llevaba a su
colonia
lo que hago es encontrarme con los
alumnos de tuba que vienen acompañados
por el ejército israelí
nos acompañó hasta la escuela para que
puedan ir a estudiar
desde 2017 hasta hoy he visto muchas
cosas niños agredidos con piedras
algunos le sangraba la cabeza otros han
sido amenazados todo para tratar de
evitar que pasen por ese camino a causa
de sus provocaciones los niños terminan
temiendo por sus vidas algunos piensan
en abandonar la escuela y otros son
realmente lo hacen
yo estoy aquí para animarlos porque
vivimos bajo ocupación
eso es un hecho no podemos hacer nada
más que aceptarlo y seguir
eso afecta mucho a los alumnos se
levantan muy temprano en la mañana se
preparan esperan al ejército y caminan
largas distancias desde su casa hasta el
lugar donde el ejército desespera a
veces el ejército se demora entonces
ellos llegan tarde a la escuela y
después de la escuela esperan mucho
tiempo al ejército llegan a sus casas
cansados agotados y con hambre están
deprimidos y frustrados y eso se refleja
en sus resultados
la violencia está aumentando este año
los colonos israelíes se volvieron más
violentos teníamos los edificios aquí y
los quemaron arrancaron los vivos y
atacaron a las huecas
me gustaría que la autoridad palestina
al menos nos muestre su apoyo
deberían defendernos y apoyarlas
deberían estar aquí cuando ocurre un
incidente deberían venir a vernos
aquí la solución de los dos estados
actualmente es vista como una quimera
[Música]
el gobierno israelí se aprovecha de esas
esperanzas que se reducen y de la
debilitada autoridad palestina
pero nuestro
pero desarrollo
un error estratégico mayor según ami
ayalón antiguo director del servicio de
inteligencia interno israelí
cada vez más palestinos ven a mahmud
abás como un traidor como un colaborador
de los israelíes
me acuerdo que cuando yo era director
del shin beth
colaboramos con las organizaciones de
seguridad palestinas
el objetivo era planificar juntos la
manera de luchar contra el terrorismo
contra el terrorismo palestino pero
también contra el terrorismo judío
siempre me decían luchamos contra
nuestros hermanos los encarcelados los
interrogamos
solo porque creemos que al final del
camino lograremos la independencia y
crearemos un estado palestino al lado de
israel
cuando dejemos de creer cuando los
palestinos en las calles dejen de creer
cuando yo ya no pueda ir al mercado para
hacer mis compras porque me dan miedo
las protestas en las calles en ese
momento olvídense de nosotros
y eso es exactamente lo que está pasando
lo vemos todos los días es muy peligroso
enfrentarse a una sociedad que piensa
que ya no tiene nada más que perder
es nacidos
la idea de un estado palestino soberano
se derrumba poco a poco y con ella la
autoridad palestina minada por la
corrupción y las querellas internas
[Música]
por eso algunos palestinos han decidido
volverse en su contra
para la está el mayor campamento de
refugiados de cisjordania un kilómetro
cuadrado para 30.000 habitantes
la autoridad palestina ha perdido casi
todo el control sobre esta zona esta
noche el campamento se prepara para
recibir a uno de los suyos
y regresa después de 17 años de
detención en una cárcel israelí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para recibirlos los milicianos de las
facciones armadas marchan hacia los
límites del campamento desde los
primeros tiros las fuerzas de la
autoridad palestina los empujan de
regreso hacia el interior de balata
evita cuidadosamente entrar cualquiera
de sus incursiones puede escalar
rápidamente
entre la multitud esta agua esta noche
va a vestido de civil su nombre es un
seudónimo y no mostraremos sus rostros
están volviendo las personas están
recibiendo a un prisionero la autoridad
no le gusta eso entonces las fuerzas de
seguridad palestinas le lanzan
lacrimógenos a las personas que la están
esperando
al igual que muchos embala está ahmad
viene de una familia vinculada al fatah
el partido que controla a la autoridad
palestina pero escogió otro camino se
enroló del grupo yihad islámica un
satélite de hamás más radical
se hace la situación política en balata
extensas hay un abismo entre la
autoridad palestina y las personas de la
lata es una crisis política grave
tenemos a mucha gente que era de fatah
pero dijeron ya fue suficiente me voy a
la residencia ahora al fatá predica el
pacifismo siempre el pacifismo y yo no
creo en la resistencia pacífica porque
la ocupación israelí no hace más que
aumentar los ataques en jerusalén save
jarra en venta en gaza
entonces escogió otro camino porque no
quiero seguir levantando las manos y
seguir repitiendo pacifismo pacifismo
uno de los hombres más poderosos del
campamento llama al tirawi es consciente
de esa ruptura miembros del fatah nunca
cita el nombre del líder actual mahmud
abás solo se refiere a su predecesor
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
no
[Música]
la difusión de armas en el campamento y
el aumento de los problemas han agravado
las tensiones con los servicios de
seguridad palestinos
cada vez hay más armas en los
campamentos de refugiados sobre todo
porque se han empezado a fabricar es
difícil vivir sin armas porque la
ocupación israelí los colonos nos atacan
por eso debería haber armas en todas las
casas no hay otra opción no hay otra
opción aparte de la resistencia
además fija y abrir el mercado
[Música]
ahmad afirma que la anulación de las
elecciones presidenciales y legislativas
influyó en su decisión de unirse al
grupo yihad islámica al igual que una
inmensa mayoría de jóvenes palestinos se
había inscrito en las listas electorales
habría podido votar por primera vez en
abril pasado cuando se acercaba en las
elecciones uno de los adversarios más
serios para el poder era nada más y nada
menos que el sobrino de yaser arafat
nacer al quichua miembro histórico del
fatah creó una lista disidente antes del
escrutinio un crimen de lesa majestad
para mahmud abás que lo excluyó
definitivamente del fatah en el corazón
del programa de nacer al kit guau estaba
la lucha contra la corrupción número de
trabajo para el gobierno palestino antes
de unirse a este nuevo movimiento
ahora nos toca a nosotros actuar
creo que la corrupción es uno de los
mayores problemas que los palestinos se
enfrentan con ese grupo de script y me
refiero a todas las formas de corrupción
lo que uno lee justo ayer o antes de
ayer no solo nos informaron sobre los
nuevos nombramientos a los cargos de
embajadores y fue horrible
se hizo de una manera horrible porque
porque se nombró a una persona solamente
por ser la hija del embajador por
ejemplo
es como si hubiéramos regresado un
tiempo en el que los señores feudales
gobernaban todo y el resto sólo eran
vasallos
como ciudadano simplemente no sé es
parte de la ecuación
solo hay un grupo de personas que se
reúnen y deciden lo que es mejor para
ellos
contratan despiden atacan y utilizan los
fondos públicos o los desvían a su
antojo
la autoridad palestina tiene serios
problemas es facing beneficios
no se elige realmente a nadie y todo
esto ocurre mientras los palestinos
financian la autoridad y financian el
régimen a través de sus impuestos pagan
y no tienen representación sobre esta
situación no puede seguir así la
extensión
es verdad que en general los palestinos
tienen muchos problemas para enfrentarse
a la autoridad
a new world y pedirle que se haga
responsable simplemente por la ocupación
israelí sin embargo la mayoría de los
fallecidos realmente están agotados y
esta situación terminará por explotar en
la cara todo el eterno world dance y
diversión son pointer will be an
explosión de facebook
aún así en cisjordania existe una
burbuja de libertad casi intocable la
universidad
aquí todos los partidos políticos
nacionales tienen representación y
participan en las elecciones
estudiantiles que se hacen cada año
la universidad palestina de birzeit es
muy especial para los palestinos porque
aquí hay elecciones
es algo para calcular en un país que no
ha tenido elecciones en tantos años
aquí es posible actuar puedo organizar
este evento incluso aunque haya sido muy
complicado
hoy este estudiante afiliado al
comunismo organiza junto con sus
camaradas un encuentro entre el hermano
de mis hermanas y los estudiantes muchos
han venido para conocer más acerca del
recorrido del opositor asesinado
rápidamente las preguntas y respuestas
se vuelven más políticas
porque al principio este asunto dio
mucho de qué hablar hubo un gran
movimiento de protesta en las calles
contra el asesinato de mis hermanas pero
ahora ya no se ve ese movimiento ha
disminuido el interés
el juego
el interés del público cada vez es más
grande pero hay menos manifestaciones en
las calles a causa de la presión de los
servicios de seguridad
las personas tienen miedo y de hecho es
por esas presiones que estamos
boicoteando el juicio
ahora se convirtió en un símbolo y todo
el mundo debería saber lo que le pasó yo
nunca había escuchado sobre su vida y
sobre lo que le pasó contado
directamente por su familia por su
hermano
en la universidad de birzeit existe esta
libertad de expresión aquí cada quien es
libre de ser la persona que quiera
los estudiantes se aferran al escrito
democrático en el que llevan a cabo sus
estudios
muchos son conscientes que al terminar
sus carreras y graduarse la realidad
será muy diferente
el día de mañana seré un profesional y
tendré que buscar trabajo para la
mayoría de los cargos a los que la voy a
postular los hijos de los dirigentes o
las personas cercanas a la autoridad
palestina tendrán prioridad no importa
que yo esté más calificado que el estado
por ejemplo existe fija verá que todas
las oportunidades de empleo en los
ministerios en las embajadas están
reservados para los hijos de los
oficiales los hijos de la clase media o
de cualquier otra clase no tenemos
oportunidades entonces nos vamos al
sector privado o trabajamos con la
ocupación nos convertimos en sus
empleados
desafortunadamente esa es la realidad
palestina
cuando hablamos con el primer ministro
palestino sobre las frustraciones de esa
juventud trato de mostrar empatía pero
sin emitir ninguna autocrítica
y al fútbol
los jóvenes tienen sus propios sueños
sus propias exigencias
quieren ver que pasan cosas progresos
tenemos un programa para el empleo de
los jóvenes pero las medidas israelíes
causan muchos extra les entiendo su
rabia entiendo lo que quiere de hecho
estamos creando un canal detención
especialmente conseguido para hablar
sobre
está pensado para los jóvenes para sus
aspiraciones para que todos los
funcionarios palestinos puedan escuchar
en ramala es el primer día del juicio
contra los 14 oficiales palestinos
presuntos asesinos de mis hermanas se
lleva a cabo delante de una corte
militar todos se declaran no culpables
la audiencia es pública pero desde que
iniciaron las declaraciones
hussein está en manos de la seguridad
preventiva
hussein el primo de mis hermanas y
testigo principal fue arrestado en su
casa en medio de la noche por las
fuerzas palestinas su familia que estaba
boicoteando el proceso se presentó ante
el tribunal
estoy aquí para mostrar que estamos
presentes después de que las fuerzas de
la autoridad palestina hayan arrestado
en nuestra casa al testigo principal
estoy aquí para mostrarles que sus
tácticas no nos dan miedo no nos
atemoriza
hussein van a paso nueve días en la
cárcel antes de ser liberado las fuerzas
de seguridad lo acusan de haber
disparado contra una casa algo que él
desmiente por completo
mientras me interrogaban y me torturaban
nunca me hablaron sobre eso sobre esa
historia de los disparos el tema
principal era nisar y que yo cambiara mi
testimonio para que las 14 personas que
lo mataron salieran inocentes ese era el
tema al principio lo hicieron con
incentivos me dijeron que podía irme al
país que quisiera me ofrecieron dinero
una buena vida de todo pero eso no
funciona con nosotros nunca habría
pensado que fueran a hacer eso sobre
todo porque somos los testigos
principales del asesinato que están
pensando no lo entiendo estamos
atrapados entre dos invasores uno es el
invasor israelí y el otro es la
autoridad de mahmud abás honestamente me
gustaría sentirme seguro en mi país
sobre todo en mi propia casa la casa es
el lugar donde uno debería sentirse
tranquilo y nosotros ya no nos sentimos
tranquilos en nuestras casas la
autoridad palestina no nos ofrece en
libertad ni dignidad
para transmitir
los palestinos se sienten huérfanos sin
perspectivas ni dirigentes
cada vez más jóvenes exigen la
disolución de esta autoridad palestina
insostenible que no ofrecen ningún
horizonte más que el de una palestina
cada vez más autoritaria
[Música]